so the podcast idea is great but why do
I actually want to start a podcast this
is what's important I wanted to show you
guys why am I actually starting a
podcast because I think if you really
don't have a strong Y with anything that
you're doing in life there's a real big
chance that it's not gonna end up being
a long time thing which you intend and
the hope it will be so I wanted to share
my why around why I'm starting my own
podcast so firstly I'm someone that
listens to podcast Bailey and that can
be anything about just general life
self-help staff business about people
that I'm interested in and because I
work as a recruiter I commute to work
text me an hour so I really utilize that
time to listen to podcast and learn
obviously on my on my way to work which
I think a lot of people do now and what
I thought was will hang on there why
don't I actually listen to something
which could help me when I get get to
work and turn up there so I started
listening to a couple of different
recruitment podcasts and none of them
really sort of hit the spot for me
really and I didn't leave me thinking
wow I learned something there or
something that I could apply him in that
day so I've been doing a recruitment
blog now for over a year and as I said a
big part of that is basically asking
questions to recruit a lot myself about
their experiences etc so I was at having
them there we can as a collective we can
learn so if I can actually speak to
other recruiters and also recruitment
business owners on the podcast and it's
down to me to really extract their
experiences to speak to them about their
failures what they learn about that
they're sick their setbacks their wins
what they put that down to then
hopefully this podcast which is the why
essentially is to give value to others
like myself
and also just people in the industry so
people can listen to it and hopefully
take at least one part of the
conversation that the thing well I
didn't think of that or wow I'm gonna
try that today and that's my my real
goal and that is my why because I think
that's what sort of power give them
value to others and that gives me great
joy and what I'm excited about
so hopefully this podcast can achieve
that and that is the why that's gonna
really drive me on and make sure that
maybe sometimes and I can't be bothered
to to make a call or do a podcast that
is gonna keep me going and that's what
gets me really excited so my why is to
give value to others in the recruitment
industry by extracting other people's
experiences and sharing that with the
world which hopefully means that we
could all learn as a collective and
become better as a collective which is
what it's all about so that's my wife
[Music]